[Musique]
soit je continue à être en colère à
déprimer même où je peux profiter de
cette pandémie
la pandémie la crise m'a aidé à changer
les choses
car le climat vit depuis deux ans à
toronto il y a un an comme bien du monde
il a perdu son emploi mais pas longvic
de changer son mode de vie
quand je travaillais j'avais pas le
temps de cuisiner ou de m'occuper de ma
santé ou de tout ça donc je me suis dit
tiens vu que je suis chez moi à la
maison pourquoi ne pas commencer à
cuisiner un peu d'embonpoint et des
problèmes de santé l'ont poussé à se
prendre en main dès le début de la
pandémie
je me suis dit un jour que j'ai 35 ans
je prends des médicaments pour la
triglycérides et un des trucs pour
l'acide urique pourquoi c'est pas c'est
pas acceptable
beaucoup moins de gras presque plus de
viande rouge est finie le grignotage de
soirée il a alors perdu une douzaine de
livres
c'était pas énorme parce que j'étais pas
en train de faire un régime alimentaire
j'étais en train de manger sain et
d'avoir un mode de vie ce ces nouvelles
qualité de vie il la doit aussi à ses
longues marches de deux trois heures
dans la ville reine
j'ai refusé le fait d'être chez moi tout
le temps à ne rien faire et je me
baladais partout partout surtout avec le
lac parce que j'aime bien c'est très
joli et le fait d'être libre dehors au
lieu d'être dans une chambre tout le
temps ça à ça aide beaucoup mentalement
son bilan de santé est en tout cas clair
ces petits pépins ont commencé à se
résorber
on voit les bienfaits entre le mois de
mai et est loin devant exactement ça
donc vous voyez la courbe comment elle
était un peu un peu trop élevé en mai et
comment elle a dramatiquement changé en
novembre
grâce à sa cuisine même son bout s'est
adapté honnêtement j'aime plus tout ce
qui est grave ben dans le temps j'aimais
et j'appréciais mais là quand je mange
quand je veux quelque chose de grammont
mon estomac il est plus habitué à ce
genre de nourriture car le climat ce
c'est que le travail reprendra un de ces
jours il espère être capable de garder
ce nouveau mode de vie quand la roue
recommencerait à tourner en attendant il
veut inspirer ceux qui sont dans la même
situation que lui et je suis fier et je
suis et même je suis contente de ce
changement parce que voilà ccc boda
tracé